je peux en avoir
alors le sujet que nous allons vous
proposer maintenant et peut-être un des
plus ambitieux qui est jamais figuré à
notre programme voilà c'est un sujet
qui est relativement moderne non que ce
phénomène n'est pas existé dans des
temps reculés mais aujourd'hui il a pris
une certaine extension et il présente
certains dangers
expliquez le fonctionnement d'une secte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue à la femme de la paix de
l'amour de la transcendance orbitale
équatoriale du pain sec de la
vinaigrette de l'eau et de l'oignon
salut votre Dieu on vous prosternant
devant le bac à légumes
le monde est un oignon
chantant à l'unisson
prosternez-vous de l'autre côté
les oignons sont là encore dit jeunes
disciple de lui montrer votre face
oh Mon pardon pardon
le monde est un oignon
chantant à l'unisson
restez à Genouillé un repas va vous être
servi
quand vous kangourou maintenant
mettre je ne vois pas les trois grains
de riz complet habituels les assiettes
sont vides
tu n'as pas besoin de visualiser ta
nourriture pour te nourrir
lèche et appréhende ton écuelle qui est
ce bel objet qui sert à te nourrir et tu
ne le connaissais pas jusqu'à lors tu
apprendras à le connaître c'est bon ah
bon
n'abuse pas tu te ferais du mal
maintenant que tu t'es bien nourri pense
à ceux qui ont faim et ceux qui
souffrent tu voudrais souffrir toi aussi
oui maître le marteau le marteau le
marteau
tu te ferais du mal
maintenant ton corps est apaisé mais tu
as encore dans ton esprit de mauvaise
pensée et de vilaines idées à vous
défauts oui maître
je m'accuse du péché de gourmandise
cette nuit en cachette je me suis relevé
je suis allé sucer un oignon dans le bac
maître je m'excuse du péché de
gourmandise je me souviens avoir bu un
verre d'eau entier dans la seule journée
d'hier
mettre
j'ai connu aussi le péché gourmandise en
plus des trois grains de riz complet à
faire par les camarades j'en ai sucé un
quatrième
pour vivre et assurer la sexualité de
groupe de ce soir je vous pose une
question préliminaire lequel d'entre
vous a réussi à accomplir l'acte
d'hypostage extasié cette nuit nous nous
mettre nous deux
lequel de vous peut recommencer la même
opération cette nuit aussi celle qui
viendra devant votre gourou à côté avec
et par la jeune femelle alors pas moi
j'en peux plus mettre j'en peux plus
avant d'aller sur vos couches et
d'avant vous
pensez-vous famille oui maître
je te donne tout je ne garde rien tu es
tout et je ne suis rien
je n'ai plus rien mettre
tu n'as plus rien à te mettre
combien as-tu fait de clients cette nuit
125 c'est bien ton cas n'est pas
désespéré tu peux aller prendre et
manger un oignon pour te rassasier
merci Maître
avant d'aller aux ateliers d'aller
prêcher la bonne parole en allant
répandre la vérité
allons faire de la musique maître Gilles
brisé ma Clochette clochette sont cassés
très bien vous serez puni on ne mangeant
pas de nourriture ni de boisson pendant
3 jours et trois nuits merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]